こんにちは
新しい年ですねで来食部の冬はフェスは雨がはいいけども
今週はね雪が降ってます
それでいいねぇ
これは私のまあいえば事務所ですね
ここで言葉も勉強するわけなんですよアイパーでがあってですね
そして私の今のビデオはこちらで作るわけですよ
こういう風な
設備デー
それじゃあはこの滅についてなぜ熱について話ししたいかというと
エコノ前
僕の良い子のそのチャンネルデー
林 d 3倫理という南アフリカの方ですけれどもシンガポーに住んでますけれども
拡張と
あのビデオでその界隈ましてね
でこの女性がものすごいネスやあるじゃあ言葉の勉強にパイして
でこのインタビューのリンクはこちらの説明を北に入れますけれども
そこでまあほとんどでも英語でしたけれども一部日本語とまぁ韓国を途中事で彼女と
話ししましたけども彼女
もうベッドな無謀だからタガログ語から半谷号がいろんな言葉に挑戦しています
も覗い熱意おります
でやはり言葉を勉強するにはその勉強する人の態度がものすごい大事なんですよそれ
まあ抗議しん
熱意
いや勉強したい知りたいこのバックことバーを通じていろんなことを知りたい
そういうような熱意が大切なんですよだけども
もし
例えばそのいろんな試験だとかドリルとか
えそのぉ
5偉業を
小懸命勉強したいとかそういうようなことがね
少なくとも僕の場合はその熱意がもう
冷めてくるんですよなくなるんですよだから
熱意をそのままもともと
まあある程度ネジがあるとしますか
そしてやはり勉強するそのいわゆる
活動というかアクティビティがない村熱意をさらに良い
あのう
強化するようなあるいはいあー少なくとも維持するような勉強法を
まあ錯覚しすればいいわけですよな利用した方がいいんですよだから勉強するときに
つまらない
誰がいくらやってもなかなか進歩しない
a 伝統的な覚え方教え方それをやはりある程度あるいは
できるだけ避けて面白いものを聞いたら人の声のスキーなないよ
内容僕にとって面白いし
理解そういうようなものを中心に勉強した方がいいんですよ
もちろん最初の3カ月間
そういうそれが新しい言葉を勉強した時に最初の3ヶ月か倫理さんはそれを新婚旅行と
言いましたよねそのときま
まったく新しい全然知らなかった言葉をある程度魚
わかるようになるとある程度何か言えることにイエロー
その
具合になったとそれが楽しいと
なんかできましたとだけでもそれはまあ3カ月間とするとその後はですねやはり
本当に流暢に話せるまでになるためには長く続かなければならない
だけでも長く続くためにですね楽しくないとダメなんですよ
だから楽しく勉強できる方法が大切だから楽しく聞いて楽しく読んで面白いものをゴリ
は本やあるいは
podcast でへそのテレビ番組なんでもいいんですけども
音楽でもね歌とかねステ級だて楽しく
そういうふうにすればそれはと行くのために一生懸命勉強するよりも楽しく
楽しいだけじゃなくて効果的です
たが効かの引ければ我々は感情的
いいその新しい言葉を受け入れやすいを受け入りたいとその体後がないと
だからそれの方へ
楽しいだけじゃなくて効果的です
でそれは3カ月間で終わらないから少なくとも
まあ一連という風に考えるべきなんですよ
だから歳3ヶ月間のいわゆるは歯にもの時に
まあある程度その突破するんですよああ
できます獅子がつくとしかし本当にん長くね
続くためにはやはり楽しく正しく
サえええ
時々進歩を感じないけれどもその勉強する過程プロセスそのものが楽しいから
別に構わないと続きた5月た1月たい
それで最終的には
リュージュにはなる可能性が多い
まあそういうようなことは教祖当たり引いてほしいですから
決心してこと時は1年
もうベーキューする
英語な英語改善するレベルアップする
えーあーところであのリンクでね
僕はいつもリンク使っていますリンクは楽しい勉強の仕方それで今4割40%割引あり
ますからここにクイックすれば
でぜひ
そうしてくださいそして続けてもう
頑張ってくださいで次のビデオはねパソコンについて話ししたいと思います
それじゃあ皆さんそれ
b 2